yeah I think a lot of people are drawing
that comparison I can see why I think
and Game of Thrones is coming to its
closure and West world is just starting
up and obviously we all know what a
massive hit Game of Thrones was and we
all hope that'll be the same for West
world and we're on a good trajectory for
that as far as shows are concerned it's
just the style they are you know
relatively different the most
science-fiction I guess from the sci-fi
fantasy but I guess I don't think too
much about how about comparing you know
I don't think about
becoming the successor to Game of
Thrones necessarily I just you know why
we want to do a good show and a great
product and do our own thing and I think
people will as if it's already started I
think people are going to show up and
and get behind our ideas and and our
concept and so I guess I don't really
think about it too much I know a lot of
people are thinking I don't know why
it's just like it's gonna take over for
Game of Thrones I I just feel like this
if there's any unnecessary pressure I
like to just sort of eliminate it and
I'm a big fan of Game of Thrones and
it's it's a testament to HBO's extremely
high quality programming and hopefully
Westworld qualifies right up there with
it
that's a good assumption because we
rarely had
much more information than the audience
has we exception of you know obviously
we would get the script to shoot the
script and sometimes we would get it
just a few days before so we we didn't
know from the showrunners where our
character arcs were going through the
season and so it was kind of a fun
mystery for us as well and that said if
we had any questions Jonah
and Lisa would all answer them and
sometimes vaguely and sometimes with
great detail because they wanted us to
know just enough to serve the story for
where we were but we had no I didn't
really have any
strong desire to know the endgame of the
first season at all I I wanted to go
along
filming like I was an audience member
like I wanted the mysteries to reveal
themselves in their own time and I think
that you know that's definitely one of
the backbones of the of the show
this all the mysteries that are
lingering and you know we're starting to
just now kind of lay our cards down and
I I encourage people to
let the show reveal what it wants to
reveal to you in its own time but I had
no problem not knowing everything that I
you know I knew everything I needed to
know I guess is what what I wanted to
say
well you know Jonah gets very he gets
very specific about he won't about how
he wants things to happen and there's
there's nothing that happens in the show
that's not there without a purpose
everything is very specific so the first
time you see the man of black shoot me
in the first episode I fall to my knees
and I keel over to my right and that
happens a few more times
not always the same kind of to the knees
and fall over but
it's you have you I put all my trust in
the showrunners on this it's the caliber
of people working on this show is is
truly remarkable it's one of the reasons
why I wanted to be a part of it so I
just I just follow Jonah's lead and yeah
and Teddy does die a lot
but I will say he's without giving too
much away he's not gonna always be
target practice
yeah
well I keep saying that my favorite
thing about being an actor is to put on
all these different costumes and by that
I mean not literally costumes but play
all these different types of characters
to step foot in all these different
types of fantastical worlds and exist in
it and I was I've been a fan of cinema
for a long time and westerns were were
something that I always loved as well so
to be riding a horse you know just
outside of arches national park and Utah
chasing the fair maiden you know with
these beautiful Beauty background
feeling like you're in a John Ford film
you know it just adds a tremendous scope
to the show and it was a dreamlike
quality to it even for me just being
there on set it was really a special
experience I guess and I think that for
the audience to see
how vast you know it is we shot a couple
of weeks out in Utah for some of those
big shots and
it adds so much to the show and it's it
is it enriches the show
it's that's a word enriches
so yeah that was hopefully we get to do
a lot more of that in season 2
[Laughter]
well no I I didn't I didn't give away
the idea just that they just announced
that they've been picked up for a season
two so I said we could we collectively
as a as a whole as a show so yeah I
can't I can't I would I wouldn't even be
in like be able to speculate on season
two at this point because like I said we
we know nothing at this point
you know and we get we would get scripts
just a few days before but you know
under the assumption that HBO has in
fact picked its show up for a second
season you know hopefully the audience
will get to see you know all of us out
there running around on horses and Utah
a lot more
season two so what do you hope that your
character can do in season two how you
would develop
well that's tough question to answer
without giving away too much but
because it would be on the assumption I
would I would have the assumption would
have to be made based on how we in this
season so but if you if you want to
speak hypothetically
you know we've watched Dolores's
evolution we watched Andy's
you know amazing awakening if you want
to call it that and I think what you're
slowly starting to see is all the hosts
these reveries start to seep into their
their consciousness and they start
they're starting to remember and so I
think I would love to see that continue
I
hate sorry to be vague
I
can't really remember them the ones that
are really twisted I try to forget
yeah I can't really I can't really think
of one specifically I had a dream last
night and Hugh Jackman was in it for
some reason I don't remember the context
but it wasn't anything nefarious it was
yeah but like I was helping him build a
build a house or something really
strange um anyway dreams were just yeah
they're crazy I can't really remember
anything specifically but shooting this
show was you know like you said it's
like I said it had a dreamlike quality
to it it was I've never done anything
like this as an actor you know
you're playing AI you're playing
essentially a robot
but we're approaching these characters
in a very human-like way you know
there's they should be indistinguishable
from humans and so but then Jonah would
come in and say okay you know that's
great as you being human human now I
want you to take where you pause a
little longer
the programming catch up with you and
then you do this you know he's very
specific I mean he's the master
puppeteer of all of us and and was just
our guide you know we and we all as a
cast kind of held hands and dove in all
it was you know none of us have either
no have you ever done this before so but
our approach should be hey we're
actually more human than some of the
humans are in this show you know we're
we have more virtue more goodness more
you know nobility loyalty and and more
of a moral code than some of the humans
do I
hope I answered your question
I think it speaks to where we are or at
least the direction we're heading with
with gaming we're starting to now see
fully immersive virtual reality gaming
and that's that's a real thing that's
happening and it's gonna continue to
evolve and
you know we we have to have the next
best best thing and I think it's not out
of the question that this will someday
something like Westworld will exist
my concern is whether or not it's good
for us I have kids and some of them do
play video games and we have to monitor
that and
but you don't want to desensitize
yourself or more importantly your
children to the effects of
this sort of virtual gaming I think one
of the things about ed Harris's
characters that you see is that he
appears to be a man who
the thrill is you know not
not as much there as it was when he
first started coming to the park and and
he wants to up the ante I guess so I
think that you see that like you start
to like become numb to these sorts of
things but but I there's a great line
from Jurassic Park also Michael Crichton
[Music]
we're Jeff Goldblum says you scientists
spent so much time wondering whether or
not they could they never stopped to
think whether they should and I just
hope there's a lot smarter people out
there that know the real ramifications
of progressing with with artificial
intelligence and all that I don't really
know how that all manifests itself but
there are some smart people out there
that are actually a little worried and
so I hope that some good discipline is
is taken
from the creators to make sure that we
don't become obsolete
[Music]
sorry
to see amusement park well
no really
there was for me it was always places I
actually wanted to go that I knew about
I mean I you know when I was a kid you
know it was the idea of this magical
whatever you want to call him coming to
your bedroom and flying you off to
Neverland you know be a mother like wake
up out of sleep and fly to some crazy
island with pirates and mermaids you
know that was kind of interesting and
then we had like the real ones like
Disneyland and and that was always
you know something very magical when
you're a kid and but I don't know that
there was one specifically I just I was
more into
boy it'd be really cool to have magic
powers or see it's superhero powers
things like that
but there was never some of the utopian
you know dreamland a museum park that
that I thought of that I don't know I
guess I my theme park was Six Flags I
would actually go in his ride
rollercoasters but but no I never really
thought about that it was a place like
West world that um but now now you got
me thinking no I wonder what that would
be for me as an adult I'll come back to
that question maybe
if I if me as James went to West world
I probably like to try bond I
mean my thing is if you're in the park
you might as well do it all right I
don't necessarily know that I derive any
sort of pleasure from some of the black
hat stuff that goes on there
you know I I believe it says more about
yourself and less about necessarily what
you're doing to this other
robot or creation I think it's just I
would want to go with the people in my
life that I feel like I know really well
my friends and watch how they behave
because I think the one thing about
Westworld is is you can be whoever you
want to be there are no consequences
there's no rules and I think if you take
humans out of that sort of
that societal constraint of civility and
you know living on earth all together in
a civil way and you can do whatever you
want I think we're gonna dive into or
some of our most primal instincts and
and maybe some of them might be a bit
ugly well it's the show you see in the
show some of the guests what they their
behavior is like but I would want to see
how my friends reveal their true
character oh I thought I knew you but
you're much your much darker than that
yeah maybe we can't be friends anymore
I find it's more more effective if I
actually acted out like I did in the
show
I'm kidding a scary you guys um yeah
that was talked about surreal dreamlike
what am i doing for a living this is
crazy
yeah I had about three page two or three
page scene with Anthony Hopkins where
I'm completely nude and he's basically
uploading a new narrative for me
and
yeah you get to work opposite one of the
greatest one of our greatest thespians
of our time and you get to sit there you
know in your birthday suit and
completely nude so
there's part of me that was nervous
about that and there's part of me that
absolutely loved that because for me
sometimes the more bizarre it gets in a
film or TV show like you know it's it's
more interesting no it's it's
representative of the
courage and the bravery that the show
takes with
presenting
themes and philosophies and so I was uh
and yeah I it was it was it was very
surreal and he was a great and he's
obviously a consummate pro so he would
kind of tell jokes and make me laugh in
between takes when they rushed over my
robe to cover myself he would launch
into Marlon Brando impersonations and
ask to tell me about his you know his
art and symphonies that he writes and
yeah fascinating man really just loves
being an actor and can turn it on like
that just like in-between he'll just
he'll make jokes and tell stories and
they'll say action he'll just be you
know one of the scariest people watch
but just you know there's just so much
going on with him but anyway so yeah it
was a that was fun actually I did up
enjoying that
well I've already probably yeah I don't
know
yeah and
we'll see I'd love to but I think it's
still
much like season 2 of Westworld it's
still very very early and so we don't
really know what's gonna be happening
but but I had a lot of fun on that movie
and
I would love to
well part of me would love to put that
suit back on because it was a pain in
the ass to wear that thing but yeah I I
think it was when you do something that
when the movie gods are smiling on you
and everything works and the talent is
there and the story's there and the
music is there and the director knows
was doing and you do something really
creative and unique and special you just
want to keep doing that you know it's
rare that all those things line up and
the formula works so I was kind of
bummed after we did that that they
didn't immediately announce another one
then but it's been what almost 10 years
9 years something since the first one so
better late than never I guess yeah
because I would love to go in and be a
part of it but those negotiations and
all that stuff I'm really started yet
but I you know hopefully I get to be a
part of it
I
did I saw the film I hadn't seen it
until I booked this role I knew of it
and I'd heard about it so it was fun -
Jonah our showrunner said go watch it he
said but just know that we're you don't
have to come back say who who's playing
the Richard Benjamin role who's playing
the
we're taking the concept and we're
making it our own
we're making it our own thing and we're
we're gonna take it to much darker
deeper levels and you know we've taken
the audience down pretty far down the
rabbit hole already so I think that's
the best way to remake something is to
take a concept that was great that maybe
didn't reach its full potential you know
and that's not a slam on the movie the
movies a great film but in two hours you
only have so much you can do so we are
able to take a much more novelistic
approach to the show on on HBO because
it affords you 10 episodes and
potentially however many years of
seasons doing it to tell all the stories
you want know what you want to tell with
as big a cast as you want so it's a
great
we've been afforded a great
latitude for a nice playground for the
potential themes that we can discuss
down the line so I watched the original
and it was great I mean Yul Brynner is
fantastic he's he's one of the scariest
villains in cinema history and it was
really the original terminator do you
think about it
yeah I wouldn't be against it at all I I
I was x-men was a really special thing
for me to be a part of and we got to be
very close as a family over the course
of nine years for me
no no sorry about six six years for me
but yeah it was it was very very cool to
be a part of and I you know I
would not be opposed to doing that again
you know those are great great jobs and
a childhood fantasy come true you know
obviously very popular I did I didn't
think it would go on this long anywhere
it's still infatuated with them you know
all the Marvel and DC characters and I
think that it's a testament to the depth
of the writing from these comic books
over the course of 50 years 60 years
that there's so many sagas and
storylines and you know different
versions of the comics so there's the
material it's so rich and I'd love to
find something else to do you know if
you're if you're allowed if you're
allowed to do that if you had to play
one character and then branch off and
play another character some of some
people I think Ryan Reynolds has done it
and who else I'm blanking now but yeah
that'd be fun they're always great
movies to be a part of
[Music]
when I was a kid I always thought I'd be
a good spider-man because I always
thought it was really skinny and I was
like you know I'd like to climb things
but um
that role has been taken
and I probably a little long in the
tooth for it now
I know there were a lot of fans out
there at one point saying that I would
make a good Hal Jordan
I'm trying to think of other guys that
yeah I I will be honest my my my
knowledge of all the characters that are
out there is relatively limited I'm you
know I'm usually like right around the
main ones that have all been we've
already seen the films and the people
who have played the characters but if
you know one you know let me know I'll
go after it
we already have Toby we have Anthony I'm
sorry I'm Andrew Andrew Garfield and
there's a new one now too right yeah I
come into play spider-man's a play
spider-man and like when he's like 50
and I'll teach the young spider-man
when I don't have to jump around so much
oh
yeah it's a wonderful place you know
I've never been to this side of the
world really my only other time to to
Asia has been to Tokyo noses for a
couple days but never been to Singapore
and
it's really been a remarkable experience
so far I'm
I'm eating my way through this country
and I've never had the most amazing food
in my life it's really really really
great the experience has been the people
have been so warm and inviting welcoming
there's a great sense of pride that I
see that everyone has here and it's you
know I what yeah I wish it's a little
more of that for back where I'm from so
it's really it's it's it's been a really
special experience and I'm learning
about all the things I need to try some
which
scare me more than others that
was a durian
and then I had some amazing chicken rice
yesterday and one of these authentic
spots and
looking forward to having some laksa oh
yeah so it's I'm I'm taking a full like
culinary approach to thing and I've
eaten more than I needed to but it's a
it's a wonderful place and and it's it's
nice to be able to come here and promote
something that you are very proud of and
also share it with like all you people
and
it's just it's this is the fun part the
works been done and now it's exciting to
get out and talk about it and actually
experience your culture